the card series three teasers out
we see a new ship we see a few other
little teasers
but
could they actually save the picard
franchise
with series three
welcome to sidetrek your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
[Music]
if you're a regular side tracker you
will know
i hated picard series one
particularly the end
the end was actually one of them it was
just
words lose me
it was so bad
that
it's really really bad
picard series 2 started brilliantly i
adored it go back and check the video
and i did a little review on the first
episode i thought it was great
i loved the designs of the stargazer 2.
i loved that you know i loved the whole
episode it was action-packed it was
exciting it was brilliant the rest of
the season
not so much
the rest of the season was
inconsistent
a little boring in places
um
not something hearing me say very often
but a little woke in places i hate that
too
and
it ended
really weekly
um
it's like the borg they're all bad
though they had to save us and it's just
it was crap
so can
the franchise
of the picard
series be saved by picard series three
well the trailer looks awesome the
trailer for picard series two looked
awesome and the trailer card series one
looked awesome not saying that that is a
trend here but just to remind you of
that
but it does actually look pretty good
what's the general gist what can we take
away from the episode
well we see a starship which looks to me
like an akira class starship and then
another vessel comes swooping in
to aid or to attack we're not quite sure
to me that looks like a ferengi ship
um
definitely an updated more modern
version but you know the colors they use
and everything if that's not a friendly
ship i'd be surprised
we see that ship the sakira class a
little bit later in the trailer where
there are three other unknown vessels
surrounding it one sat right between
themselves so to be honest that looks to
me like this
alien species that we then see in a few
seconds trying to kill dr beverly
crusher
the little alien vessel on the back of
the federation ship almost you know
looks like a tick on on the back of an
animal to me or something like that and
so yeah to me it looks like that
federation's vessel has been um captured
and in this series it looks like the
federation are 100 under attack by some
unknown enemy and we then see the
federation facility surrounded by a city
and getting hit by some sort of circular
beam then there's a pulse of energy
check out the trees
on that little on that little shot it's
a lovely little effect and the trees
just go as it gets hit and then
obviously the facility just collapses
into the ground
to me it looks like that might be some
sort of medical facility um i don't
think they would have a federation
um military facility surrounded by a
city like that we then get an
introduction into the all the other crew
now there's a little i thought they were
hinting here again that the federation
hadn't actually given permission for
their mission picard is sort of they're
going to
riker and saying oh it's time for a road
trip we need a ship and all this sort of
thing and it just smacked a little bit
of like maybe the federation actually
weren't given permission to do this and
they were having to do it on the sly
but then they're aboard a federation
shuttle
the command crew of the titan a which
i'll talk about in a minute um a very
receptive we see seven of nine who
should be a captain but it hinted in
this they called her a commander but i
wonder if he's not actually talking to
seven of nine when he says commander um
because then 79 sits in the middle c for
the captain's seat so unless the captain
isn't there for some reason now there's
two possibilities now like i said he
wasn't actually speaking to and 709 is
the captain or the captain isn't there
because they're stealing the ship
but
i just i just got hints of that but i
think i'm more worried that they can't
really go there again can they they've
done that so many times but if that's
the story then they're they're basically
borrowing the titan or they don't really
have permission that's going to be
[ __ ] and they've done it before and
i really hope they don't do it again
they've done it before in picard so
let's hope that's not it so let's talk
about the titan a really quickly because
i'm a massive geek for ship designs i i
i love them um picard series two that
was a big thing for me in the first
series that we got saw lots of new ships
we actually even got to see an odyssey
class which i'm really hoping is they're
going to follow beta cannon really and
have the enterprise f as and we're gonna
see the enterprise in this series picard
series three i hope i begged for it in
series two it made sense for series two
um but let's really hope they follow
through with series three and it has
already been hinted by a couple of the
crew and a couple of the staff cast
but this titan a it's a new constitution
class
it's ugly as hell
so they put like a constitution class
saucer or supposed to look like one and
it's very similar it's got the deep
sides and the and the shape is very
similar to a constitution
they then have the weirdest looking
deflector and very armored there's no
windows around it which kind of makes
sense they've thought that through
because you know it's a massive energy
projection device you wouldn't really
want to have your quarters above it
um
but it's very small and it's just look
to me it just looks crap i don't like
the impulse engines there's loads of
them and the ones goes right way around
the edge of the um back of the saucer
it's just a horrible looking design
there are sections of it that are a bit
similar to what we saw in the new
stargazer last term
and i assume this is going to be
designed with borg technology again um
maybe we'll see whether they mention
that or not and but generally speaking
i hate that design it's horrible it
looks
sort of like
moderny in places and old in places and
it's just a mix mash of design shapes
for me i don't like it
um
i loved for example in picard season two
that they did a new um excelsior class
and that looked wicked um i'd hoped
they'd have carried on with the new ship
designs new excitement ship designs into
this but so far they haven't but if we
see that pile of crap next to an odyssey
class enterprise f i will be a very
happy bunny so what about the other
characters that we get to see well it
does look like gates mcfadden's dr
beverly crusher is the one that causes
all the trouble so she is seen on the
advert on the trailer calling for picard
saying we need your help and then she's
seeing with a phaser and we see these
aliens click to click um coming aboard a
ship we don't know where she is we don't
know what she's doing but she needs help
so it would seem to me that this series
is going to at least start
with
picard and riker and everybody going to
try to save beverly from whatever
trouble she's got herself into i assume
it will then evolve into a threat that
is actually going to threaten the entire
federation remember the episode from the
first series of tng conspiracy where the
aliens down the throat and the things
we never got a conclusion to that
i wouldn't mind if it's them we see
jordan laforge very briefly we know he's
a parent in this we've seen some set
photos because it's actually his real
daughter that plays his daughter on the
show we do see wharf very briefly and
there's a lot of rumors going around
that cisco might be in this series and
that actually
wolf is aboard deep space nine the color
code in behind dwarf in the very brief
moment that we see him is very orangey
and brown
so
it could be a klingon ship but i doubt
it i think it's going to be deep space
nine two
um i think they know the creators of
this show know
we'd go crazy for that um so to be it
seems like a really easy win just to
have war for deep space nine when they
go find him do i think this series could
be any good
no
alex kirtman actually seems to have
found his mojo and maybe
they could save picard series three now
that cartoons three will not be on
amazon as far as we can tell it is going
straight to paramount plus so picard
series one had me excited
and they tricked me
but they that's on me i should have
known better
picard series two tricked me now that's
just me
and kurtzman needs a kick for that
i have
zero expectations of picard series three
i think it's going to probably start
very very well and it'll probably be
brilliant in the first episode and then
they'll get into the storyline and it
will probably be crap
it'll be an awful lot of look at the
character we've brought back
and
not much substance
we know it's the final series
and that is a good thing
i've loved having these characters back
and this timeline back
i loved the next generation i don't
think they should have done
discovering things i think they should
have just done a continuation of that
timeline we should have just had seen
the next generation of the next
generation
um on a different ship maybe
but they didn't they did prequels and
things and
discovery
so i've really enjoyed getting back into
a time frame and a timeline that i feel
comfortable with and that i love
i wish they'd done it better
so let's see
we'll give it a chance we'll go into it
with an open mind because you never know
they might actually pull their thumbs
out of their backsides and do a good
series and
picard and these characters deserve a
good series
they deserve this to be excellent
because we've been let down twice
already
so what do you think please get into
their comments tell me exactly what you
think of picard series 3 what did you
think of the trailer are you excited or
do you think it's just going to be more
of the same old crap
if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit that bell
notification it really helps us out also
consider becoming a fully fledged
sidetracker and hit the join button
because that really helps support the
channel
as always please stay safe and i'll see
you next time
[Music]
you